l'hebdo politique bonsoir et bienvenue à
tous dans l'hebdo politique votre rendez
vous politique du dimanche soir sur
radio sensations en association avec tv
78 épisodes 204 mon invité ce soir et
philippe jura vers conseiller régional
elle fit à la région ile de france
[Musique]
les politiques
philippe jura vers bonsoir bonsoir on
vous êtes retraité de la ratp où vous
avez travaillé comme commercial mais
aussi comme conducteur de trains
notamment sur la ligne b du rer vous
avez menées en parallèle non carrière de
syndicaliste
en 2009 vous êtes engagé en politique
alors pour quelle raison en 2009 je me
suis engagé en politique parce que je me
suis rendu compte que rester simplement
sur le terrain syndical ne suffisait pas
obtenir par les lois on peut obtenir
aussi et pour pouvoir aller sur les lois
il faut aussi les comprendre vous allez
à coeur je suis
engagé en rencontrant j'ai fait une
rencontre celle de jean luc mélenchon
qui est venu sur le terrain me soutenir
dans les luttes et à cette occasion on a
fait connaissance il était à l'époque
sénateur et donc
il prenait souvent la ligne b du rer et
j'étais conducteur donc on avait souvent
l'occasion de se rencontrer d'échanger
et on a compris qu'on pouvait faire un
bout de chemin ensemble et c'est comme
ça que depuis on était plus jamais
quittés qu'est ce qui vous a plu dans sa
personnalité dans sa personnalité c
était sa capacité à comprendre les
luttes sur le terrain et sa cape et
c'est à comprendre nos problèmes de
revendications et pouvoir échanger
simplement avec avec les agents qui
m'entouraient avec les salariés et j'ai
eu l'occasion évidemment tout de suite
d'aller dans quelques entreprises avec
lui j'ai vu cette facilité qui avait à
communiquer et à s'intégrer dans toutes
les rencontres qu'il faisait et ça ça
m'a plu beaucoup et comme j'avais à
coeur de faire progresser mes idées sur
un plan social j'ai trouvé que c'était
la voie qui ne peut les prendre alors
d'abord au parti gauche puis ensuite à
la france à bord au parti de gauche
quand il a quitté le parti socialiste
donc d'abord aux partis de gauche et
puis alors il faut savoir pour la petite
anecdote que je venais de m'engager avec
le parti socialiste parce que je
cherchais une voix il va même devoir
politique et quand il rencontre jean luc
mélenchon j'ai quitté parti socialiste
et à l'époque celui qui me suivaient
n'était autre que benoît hamon qui donc
est maudit mais philippe que fais tu
fais une erreur en allant rejoindre
jean-luc et portant de j'ai rejoint jean
luc et ça n'a pas empêché y compris avec
benoît man 2 recroiser nos chemins par
la suite mais c'était très formateur
pour moi sur un plan politique
et personnelle parce que je ne suis
rendu compte que en effet on est avant
tout tous des politiques et se résumer à
faire que du syndicalisme ça ne suffit
pas alors pour cela vous avez été
candidat notamment aux élections
européennes en 2010 f g élections rey
était candidat ça c'est un apprentissage
très compliqué surtout quand on vient
vraiment du monde du travail et qu'on a
été syndicaliste
séparer les choses c'est pas une chose
facile y compris quand vous rechercher
des soutiens autour de vous et et donc
il a fallu convaincre convaincre du bien
fondé de se porter candidat parce qu'il
suffisait pas de faire de la politique
pour paraître mais pour être un acteur
et être un acteur c'est porter un poids
de responsabilité c'est porte parole de
toutes celles et ceux que vous
représentez et c'est une sacrée
responsabilité
vous êtes aujourd'hui et conseiller
régional voit la région ile-de-france
mais la prochaine échéance politique
c'est l'élection présidentielle dont le
premier tour aura lieu le 10 avril 2022
jean luc mélenchon s'est déclaré très
tôt comme candidat c'était en novembre
2020 ah c'était le meilleur taille mais
oui à chaque fois c'est la troisième
campagne que je fais aussi avec les jean
luc mélenchon et à chaque fois il s'est
présenté tôt pour justement permettre
d'une part de biens fusé tout le
programme est tout ce que nous avions
affaire et permettre des échanges aussi
pour être porté le plus largement
possible autour de lui par la france
insoumise déjà dans un premier temps et
puis dans le cas de l'union populaire
au-delà de la france est soumise on se
souvient qu'à l'époque il ya quelques
hésitations entre lui et françois ruffin
notamment jean luc mélenchon se présente
pour la troisième fois à l'élection
présidentielle c'était toujours la
meilleure personnalité pour incarner le
programme il de la violence face aux
mises je ne vous cache pas eu un débat
très ouvert à l'intérieur de la france
insoumise j'ai participé à ce débat
françois ruffin s'est posé des questions
d'autres se sont posés également des
questions mais le consensus a été trouvé
on fonctionne beaucoup par consensus à
la france insoumise et ce consensus a
été trouvé que cette étape arrivée au
moment où le président de toute façon
quels qu'ils soient ont pour nous devait
céder la place pour laisser la place
donc à une sixième république où ne
figure pas le président de la république
donc il était l'homme idéal pour pouvoir
représenter ce que nous défendons jo
depuis bien des années alors ce
programme justement vous l'avais appelé
l'avenir en commun les grandes lignes
ont été déjà tracée en 2017 qui a
participé à l'élaboration de ce
programme alors on est nombreux à
pouvoir avoir participé déjà tous les
élus mais également de nombreux
contributeurs il ya énormément de
groupes d'appui à la france insoumise
qui envoient des contributions donc qui
sont centralisés
par notre organisation et on essaie de
dégager les grandes idées et faire vivre
des débats sur les territoires mais au
plus près du terrain à chaque fois on se
contente pas de faire une élection à
travers des élus les élus ne sont que
des porte-parole mais bien celles et
ceux qui nous représentent et donc ces
groupes d'appui ces groupes de lutte qui
nous entoure en rôle prépondérant dans
la façon de concevoir le programme s'il
ya eu des modifications depuis 2010 est
alors il ya eu des modifications ce sens
qu'on a fait son départ un sondage
des grandes idées de notre programme et
on s'est rendu compte que certaines de
ces idées méritait une attention plus
particulière notamment concernant
l'agriculture puisqu'on a décidé de
passer d'un ministère de l'agriculture
ministère de l'alimentation est
également dans le cas de la transition
écologique ans s'est rendu compte qu'il
y avait beaucoup plus de profondeur à
faire pour pouvoir faire conjointement
évoluer le social et l'écologie il ya
une transformation sociale qui se fait
dans notre pays et d'où les 100
milliards nous avons décidé de mettre
mais qui enveloppent évidemment tout un
panel de formations de deux créations et
d'investissement pour pouvoir faire en
sorte que l'écologie et sociales
puissent vivre ensemble est donnée cette
transformation sociale qu'on appelle
dans le cas de l'écosystème et et que
nous avons à défendre et surtout le
danger que nous avons affronté le
dérèglement climatique qui lui n'attend
pas et donc apporter de réponse urgente
et vous sur quelle partie du programme
vous êtes vous le plus investi bon puis
naturellement je me suis investi sur le
côté social pourquoi parce que j'ai un
passif de ce côté là et j'ai un réseau
très important aussi à travers l'espace
des luttes et ça me permet de sonder
régulièrement nos idées et de voir en
complète le plus utile à la france un
soumises pour tout ça est ce qu'on
représente notamment dans les luttes
actuellement et
à travers toutes les déréglementations
social qui lie à dans le pays on se rend
compte qu'il ya une urgence à gérer et
là dessus je porte mes idées à jean luc
mélenchon notamment pour lui dire ô
combien il doit abroger certaines noah
je crois que ses premiers messages qu'on
doit apporter aux gens qui nous écoutent
l'abrogation de certaines lois qui
actuellement font que
il n'y a plus de vie véritablement
social dans les entreprises après un
quinquennat marqué notamment par l'ailé
gilet jaune la crise des gilet jaune
quel constat faites vous aujourd'hui sur
le plan social alors les gilet jaune
c'est vrai que ça a été une éruption un
petit peu dans notre vie politique on
s'attendait pas à ce qu'un tel mouvement
puisse prendre une telle ampleur ça
bouscule et aussi beaucoup le mouvement
syndical qui sortait d'une hutte très
éprouvante
les années précédentes
gilet jaune est ce ça n'a fait que
confirmer que cette révolte citoyenne
pouvait prendre toutes les formes qu'on
pouvait imaginer pour l'instant ce sont
les gilets jaunes qui sont toujours là
du reste mais on pense qu'il pourrait y
avoir aussi et d'autres réactions des
rêveurs des révoltes au niveau des
quartiers populaires des révoltes au
niveau des étudiants des jeunes de la
jeunesse des révoltes et toutes ces
révoltes en populaires font que elle
demande des revendications précises et
beaucoup s'appuie d'après les sondages
qu'on a pu mettre en avant comme le smic
comme un acteur du swing comme le le
revenu minimum pour les pour les jeunes
comme la relocalisation de certains
certains points essentiels dans notre
pays va toutes ces revendications commun
en place sont portés par toutes ces
révoltes convoi dans dans la rue et la
joie le gilet jaune qui avait porté une
révolte sur l'augmentation du prix de
l'essence on voit qu'aujourd'hui avec ce
qui se passe avec l'augmentation encore
à nouveau de l'essence les biens
supérieure à celle qui était celle de
2018 il pourrait très bien y avoir à
nouveau une révolte des gens qui tous
les jours sont obligés condamné à
prendre leur voiture notamment pour se
déplacer écologie à la région eh bien ça
me permet d'échanger avec madame
pécresse sur ce sujet ô combien
difficile en algérie nous allons
maintenant rentrer dans le détail du
programme social de l'avenir en commun
en nous intéressant à plusieurs points
vous en avez évoqué quelques-uns vous
souhaitez d'abord revenir sur les
privatisations
alors pourquoi l'intérêt général et il
attaque et lorsque l'état privatiser
l'entreprise alors privé des
privatisations ça donne toujours la même
chose c'est-à-dire que pour pouvoir
qu'elle quel est l'objectif de la
privatisation c'est de faire des profits
il n'y a pas 36 façons de faire des
profits il faut jouer sur la masse
salariale il faut jouer sur les coûts
des prix et on voit ce qui s'est passé
récemment pour l'énergie avec edf gdf ou
d'une explosion des prix malgré cette
prime et des privatisations qui était
largement demande est faite une époque
sans montas à l'époque de nicolas
sarkozy mais aujourd'hui on se rend
compte que ces dix dernières années une
augmentation de 40% des prix on voit que
en février 2022 on sera également
exposés à une augmentation de 12% des
prix au niveau de l'énergie électrique
on pense qu'à un moment donné cette fin
de monopole il faut se poser la question
de savoir si quand on veut sortir cette
catastrophe sociale est ce qu'il ne faut
pas penser à une certaine forme de
monopolisation de dvd d
essence est essentielle pour pour la vie
c'est-à-dire ya l'énergie il ya
certainement d'autres secteurs où il
faut repenser je pense aux transports
notamment en ile de france où il faut
repenser aussi à faire vivre des
monopoles même si c'est temporaire de
telle manière à pouvoir maîtriser
réguler les prix et faire en sorte qu'on
ne puisse pas la précarité autour de
nous parce que c'est ce qui est
condamnable aujourd'hui c'est que ça
touche les plus fragiles et par la
privatisation par l'ouverture à la
concurrence on s'est rendu compte que ça
accentue et d'un côté
la pauvreté et permis à une minorité de
terriblement s'enrichir sans commune
mesure là on sait que les prix vont
exploser au niveau des profits vont
exposer encore pour 2022 et je crois que
ces inégalités sociales dans le pays
font que iliad monte en voit bien de
l'extrême extrême droite notamment des
extrêmes et donc à travers ces extrêmes
on voit apparaître
un acteur politique pour ne pas le
nommer monsieur zemmour qui a su se
saisir de cette opportunité pour pouvoir
faire entendre sa musique est soulagé
les peurs les angoisses de 2 millions de
français on vous proposait aussi de
relocaliser d'urgence les productions
essentiel au pays on en a parlé
notamment pendant les périodes de
confinement à quels domaines pensez vous
en priorité pendant un temps je pensais
aussi à luxfer luxe faire c'est donc ces
bouteilles d'oxygène pendant la pandémie
on était on travaille avec eux et ils
avaient tous les atouts pour pouvoir
produire sur notre pays et
malheureusement on est obligés
d'aller chercher cet oxygène notamment
en turquie et ailleurs je pense aussi à
relocaliser des choses essentielles
comme le vélo qui a explosé là
dernièrement
dans notre pays c'est justement lié tout
ce que nous avons vécu au niveau de
cette crise les dérailleur shimano qui
sont produits en asie
pour l'instant sont retenus pour
différentes raisons en asie et
aujourd'hui pour pouvoir commander un
vélo il faut parfois un an voilà donc il
ya des choses essentielles comme ça pour
pouvoir permettre
à chacun de pouvoir vivre relocaliser
aussi des industries
agricoles comme le comme le maïs quand
on est obligé d'importer de très loin
pour pouvoir nourrir les pôles et
pendant ce temps là on n'est pas capable
de produire sur place ne serait-ce que
des carottes pour pouvoir alimenter les
cantines de proximité dont je crois que
il ya tout un autre de penser à mettre
en avant et dans notre programme
justement on pense à cette façon de
pouvoir vivre au plus près à proximité
et se sentir mettre un petit peu de
notre stratégie si on souhaite en mettre
une
alimentaire sanitaire industriel changer
notre est connue passera notamment par
des investissements
emmanuel macron a présenté la semaine
dernière son plan france 2030 avec 30
milliards on est investissements dans
les énergies dans l'électronique la
robotique et transport et enfin la santé
est-ce que ce plan france 2030 répondent
ils aux enjeux alors s'il répond une
partie aux enjeux il reste du domaine de
l'incantation c'est à dire que c'est le
ni oui ni non
il met 4 milliards dans un premier temps
et le reste s'il est élu j'ai bien
compris c'est un peu cette forme de
chantage qui te présentes et donc dans
ce qu'il veut mettre en avant c'est à
dire faire un peu d'écologie mais pas
trop dire on veut bien pousser sur
l'agriculture même temps on veut recréer
du nucléaire et donc investir dans le
nucléaire on veut bien investir dans le
numérique mais en même temps on verra si
la sainte gse se produira ou pas dans
notre pays voilà donc cela en même temps
et cette façon de dire ni oui ni non ne
nous convient pas je crois que les gens
ont besoin d'un cap clair et pour ça il
faut répondre à des choses claires par
exemple quand il ya eu cette histoire
d'augmentation de
des salaires des professeurs on a été
clair dans la manière où on a proposé
nous une augmentation qui répondait à
celle des syndicalistes venir 15%
d'augmentation pour pouvoir rattraper
dit peu leur salaire ce qui représente
17 milliards d'investissements c'est
mesurable c'est quelque chose de concret
et je crois que les français attendent
quelque chose de concret quelque chose
qui leur parlent directement or vous à
la france a soumis ce vous proposer un
plan d'investissement de 100 mille deux
cents milliards d'euros pour je cite
lancé la bifurcation de notre économie
alors que ferez-vous avec ses 100
milliards d'euros 5,5 milliards là je
vous proposais déjà 17 pour ce qui est
des aspects soeur il faudra évidemment
le plus gros ça va être sur la
transformation écologique et pour
pouvoir
s'occuper du nucléaire s'est accompagné
le nucléaire et non pas le supprimer du
jour au lendemain mais c'est aussi tout
un travail de formation pour pouvoir dé
construire ces centrales la joie qui a
tout un programme qui est lancé pour les
voitures concernant
les voitures électriques mais les
voitures électriques là aussi il ya tout
un travail à faire pour pouvoir
construire des bases qu'ils puissent
construire les batteries comment penser
à
à pouvoir accompagner
la gestion de ces déchets radioactifs
bon stas et ça représente un coût très
important la partie agricole également
formé plus de 300 à gruissan
agriculteurs qui puisse être trois cent
mille agriculteurs qu'ils puissent être
au plus proche du terrain pour une
agriculture paysanne
ça demande beaucoup de moyens ça demande
aussi un temps infini pour la formation
et je crois que c'est 100 milliards
d'une part organisé
pour la transition écologique d'autre
part pour pouvoir permettre de
réindustrialiser relocaliser une
certaine industrie et faire en sorte que
ces deux pentes puissent coopérer dans
le temps je crois qu'il y aura pas assez
d'un mandat pour pouvoir faire en sorte
qu' on puisse construire un avenir
meilleur pour chacun 100 milliards c'est
quelque chose qui lorsqu'on le
l'écrivait le disait en 2017 faisait
rire beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui on est
très très très loin de ce que peuvent
brasser notamment macro et l'europe pour
pouvoir faire autre chose que du bien
pour le plus grand nombre et pour la
jeunesse aussi si on sait que c'est un
thème qui vous tient à coeur et vous
souhaitez mettre en place une allocation
autonomie moller qui pourrait en
bénéficier dans quelles conditions oui
alors cette allocation évidemment pour
les moins de 25 ans
et pour ceux qui font des études elle
est importante c'est une urgence on peut
pas quand on revivre ce qu'on a vu
encore il ya un an pandas durant la
pandémie et il suffit d'un kilomètre de
jeunes qui cherchent à se nourrir dans
beaucoup de femmes beaucoup de jeunes
femmes qui elles
avait beaucoup d'emplois précaires en
même temps qu'elle faisait leur étude du
fait de la pandémie tous ces emplois ont
été supprimés et sans trouver sans
moyens pour pouvoir
pour pouvoir faire leurs études et puis
vivre tout simplement donc je pense que
cette ces conditions d'accès pour
pouvoir avoir droit à
ses moyens qu'on va mettre en place ça
s'adresse à des jeunes de moins de 25
ans qui actuellement
ont des bourses d'études mais ne
suffisent pas à pouvoir gérer leurs
études on voudrait faire en sorte que
ces jeunes puissent réellement étudié et
ne pas se perdre dans des emplois
précaires qui les conduit bien souvent
deux sur trois à abandonner leurs études
ces allocations à dominer sa d'un
montant de combien alors on est en train
de
réfléchir à la somme mais
évidemment on se rapproche du seuil de
pauvreté
donc
le chiffre exact on le donnera quand on
on aura pris toute la mesure de la qui
ont d'attributs exactement ces sommes
mais elle se rapprochera du soulier pour
voter bonsoir durée du temps de travail
maintenant on connaissait le slogan de
nicolas sarkozy travailler plus pour
gagner plus chez vous à la france a
soumis ses travailler moins pour
travailler tous nos voisins espagnols
vont expérimenter la semaine de quatre
jours c'est ce que vous souhaitez
également pour la france oui on salue
d'un jeu d'ailleurs
ce travail qui est fait par
des espagnols daniel rault sanchez là
qui va expérimenter sage pendant 250
villes mais c'est quelque chose qui est
très important parce que aujourd'hui
quand monsieur macron dit que les
français ne produisent pas assez c'est
faux ils produisent justement plus en
travaillant pour l'instant à 35 heures
mais malheureusement se rend compte que
dans beaucoup d'entreprises actuellement
j'ai été voir une société comme bergues
hans
beaucoup d'entreprises parce que il y à
des dérogations au code du travail
actuellement on fait travailler beaucoup
plus les salariés pour travailler pour
gagner beaucoup moins et pour avoir
beaucoup plus de production mais pour
qui cette production aujourd'hui on est
dans un cadre de vie il faut savoir ce
qu'on veut produire pour cas l'intention
si c'est uniquement pour faire du profit
et ne pas rendre aussi un besoin
nécessaire à chacun et lui donner un peu
de vie pour pouvoir profiter de son
expérience de vie ça ne sert à rien
je crois que cette pandémie nous a
appris ça le besoin de vivre on a eu
chacun une expérience mené durant toute
cette année 2020 et on s'est rendu
compte que par le télétravail mais
également par d'autres façons de qu'on
était capable de vivre autrement et de
vivre en dehors du travail le travail en
a besoin il ya trop de chômeurs entre
précarité mais on a aussi besoin de
vivre dernière question sur la partie
sociale du programme de l'avenir en
commun faut-il augmenter le smic alors
c'est une nécessité pour plusieurs
raisons
vous voyez aujourd'hui tout le monde est
d'accord tout tout tout candidat
confondues tout le monde est d'accord
pour dire on ne peut plus vivre en
dessous du seuil de pauvreté voilà donc
aujourd'hui que soient retraités ou
actifs on ne peut plus vivre au dessus
du seuil de pauvreté mais
malheureusement ce seuil de pauvreté
était qu'il est estimé à un peu plus de
1000 euros on se rend compte que l'on
survit à ce prix là il faut absolument
aller au niveau du smic pour les minimes
hommes tels qu'ils soient or pour cela
il faut augmenter aussi le smic on veut
pas le laisser un 1200 euros nets c'est
pas possible donc pour le monter à 1400
à 1500 euros net eh bien il faut déjà
dans un premier temps augmenter ce ce
smic de telle manière que tous les
minima sociaux puissent être calé par
rapport au smic et ça permettra à tout
le monde d'avoir une unité de mesure à
savoir on peut non pas survivre mais
vivre avec le minimum à savoir le smic à
l'heure actuelle aucun candidat de
gauche nette au second tour selon les
sondages d'opinion est ce que cela vous
préoccupe actuellement non non pour
pour une seule raison c'est que le
phénomène monsieur zemmour a appris une
chose c'est que si réellement il porte
sa candidature il semble le vouloir
on voit très bien que dans les sondages
la barre pour pouvoir être deuxième tour
bat b c et va permettre à beaucoup plus
de candidats d'accéder notamment nous au
deuxième tour je crois qu'à ce moment là
dès que les candidatures vont se
concrétiser on verra que
on rentrera dans le fond de notre
programme et que cette possibilité de
deux études de deuxième tour s'ouvrir à
tous y compris à jean luc mélenchon et
on compte bien être présent pour ce
deuxième tour et à terme une alliance
comme vous l'avez réalisés lors des
élections régionales est elle possible
pour l'élection présidentielle je pense
qu'elle est possible contrairement à ce
qu'on peut penser
sachez que le dialogue existe malgré des
apparences je vois que j'ai entendu ce
matin
donc le responsable du parti socialiste
chez monsieur bourdin évoqué
pour l'instant le nom rapprochement mais
dans le bisontin franchement avec la
france insoumise mais je vois que les
questions se posent aujourd'hui et
sachez que quelles que soient les bords
politiques
quand on parle d'union populaire on
parle à toutes ces femmes et ces hommes
quelles que soient les alliances qu'ils
ont quel que soit le parti que les
appartiennent pour pouvoir converger
vers des idées qu'ils ne soient communes
et ça c'est possible pour terminer cette
émission nous allons évoquer la
situation régionale en tant que
conseiller régional d'île de france vous
êtes fortement investis sur les
questions de mobilité et sur les
transports votre ancienne carrière la
ratp n'y est pas par hasard vous avez
obtenu une réunion pour relancer le
projet de la réalisation d'un double
tunnel pour les rer b et d c'est un
projet qui pourrait faciliter la vie de
nombreux franciliens alors 1 million 600
mille voyageurs par jour pour le rer b
et d et il faut savoir que
j'étais assez surpris à la région
puisque je suis un nouvel élu assez
surpris de voir que cette idée de
deuxième tunnel a été relayée depuis
2011 a été relayée de côté pour faire
place à un au système informatique qui
va permettre d'automatiser une partie de
la circulation mais qui ne donnera pas
de garantie sur une possibilité
d'exploiter
d'optimiser la circulation des trains
est d'apporter plus de sécurité et dans
la circulation il faut savoir qu'un
double tunnel à châtelet sa doublerait
pratiquement la circulation des trains
ça permettrait de mettre le rer b sur un
site propre le rer d sur un site propre
et ne plus converger comme c'est le cas
actuellement à châtelet cessons de ligne
qui se croisent et une circulation
alternée fait que au moindre incident
qui vient sur la ligne c'est un retard
abyssal qui se prend sur la ligne est
donc ce sont deux lignes ils sont
totalement sclérosé et depuis des années
à cause de ça je vis cette ce combat
depuis 2008 sur la ligne b où a été mis
en place une aberration encore une
interopérabilité une circulation ratp et
sncf où on nous a fait croire qu'en
supprimant une relève de conducteurs à
châtelet on allait pouvoir doubler la
circulation sous tunnel d'être à ça à
était faux la seule chose qu'il faudrait
c'est mettre en double tunnel pourquoi
ça ne se réalise pas que pour une chose
c'est que pape aux deux raisons
simplement technique mais parce qu'on ne
peut pas contrairement au grand paris
pouvoir faire du profit ig et à
l'urbanisme regardez comment se
construit le grand paris de partout le
prix du mètre carré monte et la
possibilité soit beaucoup de choses
regarder à gare du nord ils étaient
prêts à faire des grandes salles de
grandes des grands magasins mais là dans
un double tunnel à châtelet on ne peut
pas faire ça dans sa vie des ruptures de
charge un désagrément pendant 6 8 mois
pour pour évidemment des voyageurs et
pas simplement des clients des citoyens
qui prennent le train tous les jours
mais si on leur apportait ce bien-être
ça serait quelque chose de pérenne qui
permettrait enfin à
haha
d 1 million 600 mille voyageurs
fait quelque chose de concret pour nous
et on trouve on suivra l'évolution de la
situation merci lire j'en avais d'avoir
été avec nous dans l'hebdo politique je
rappelle que vous êtes conseiller
régional elle est fille à la région ile
de france et nous on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de l'hebdo politique très bonne soirée à
tous
[Musique]
les politiques